hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
monday monday monday
may 17th monday may 17th
what's going on dude they listen the
summer's already going by before you
even know it
okay we know it's the summer out here
because we're in l.a we already had our
first fire
out there in the palisades i think they
put it out shout out to all the firemen
out there i know that wasn't an easy one
um you know
i'd lied to you if i wasn't thinking
like you know what if i got so good at a
helicopter i could be one of those
people coming in dive bombing with the
[ __ ] water
coming by with a bucket india infinity
pool i would deliberately pick some rich
[ __ ] house
and [ __ ]
drop the bucket right in there
trying to save your house there [ __ ]
escobar
um anyway
um shout out to them man and uh
we got lucky today it seemed like the uh
there was really no wind
and the uh and it rained a little bit so
at least over where the hell i'm at um
but it was uh kind of cool where uh
i'll tell you i went i took my daughter
with a with a buddy of mine
his dad i know goes to the same school
as my kid
barbara's daughter does so uh we took
the kids to go see toy story
right now those of you who listen
to my podcast know that uh about a
before the pandemic
i was so excited to take my kid to the
movies
that i took her to go see dumbo not
realizing that it was this sort of bram
stroker's [ __ ] whatever the hell
guy's name is you know freddy krueger's
[ __ ] dumbo
it was dark and all you know it was like
for adults
i went in there it was nothing but
adults in there i'm like this is weird
these [ __ ] people need to get over
their childhood man
you know it's dumbo the last happy day
you had so you couldn't wait for this to
come out why are all these adults here
i got there and i noticed like the
trailers for the movies
you know before dumbo were really adult
themed like i don't think kids should be
seeing this this seems weird i wasn't
really clocking my
kid because you know i was new to being
a dad and
first time i took in the movies so
anyway we lasted about six minutes in
and it was scary it was super dark and
like the
[ __ ] beating the [ __ ] out of the
elephant and all there yeah [ __ ] big
ears you piece of [ __ ]
wasn't that bad but that's what it felt
like when i was with my daughter and she
just looked at me and i just said hey
buddy
uh you want to get out of here and she
just goes yeah so i go
let's bring the popcorn so we brought
the popcorn and all of that type of
stuff so
it's like a good year and a half or
whatever later
um this buddy of mine goes hey let's
take the kids to go see uh toy story am
i perfect toy story i know what happens
in toy story fine
so we go you know he gets the tickets i
get the uh the concessions right we go
in there we're having a great time
beautiful theater i'm psyched to be back
in the movies right
um there's like literally like five
other people in there so everybody's
nice and spread out because i don't get
that whole rule like you have to have a
mask on inside unless you're eating
well do i have to hold my breath while
i'm eating what are we doing right
whatever so um
we start to watch it and then once again
the movie trailers before
[ __ ] toy story were all adult themed
like they sh they they're doing the
cruella de vil
story like the backstory to see how she
became
who she was in the animated version
which i thought was a really cool idea
mike our kids didn't think so much at
least my kid didn't right
you know and she's just like i'm cruella
de vil she's just being a [ __ ]
lunatic right
cokehead running around dogs are
growling at her and [ __ ] and she's got
the crazy hair
it's live action and it kind of looked
like they were doing sort of
uh you know batman meets the joker
backstory right
like all right that was kind of weird
then they cut to like this marvel
the next one some marvel movie you know
superhero movies are like i'm gonna
[ __ ]
punch you in the face yeah i'll combat
you with my laser eyes
i was screaming and yelling and
buildings falling down and [ __ ]
swords and hammers
and i see my daughter she's like she's
like pulling her knees up and she's
grabbing my arm and [ __ ]
i'm like not what the [ __ ] are they
showing this [ __ ] before the goddamn toy
story
so we finally get the toy story i'm like
all right okay we're in okay we got
through the bad neighborhood now we're
into the [ __ ] we're at the mall
so um
we're watching it and then it gets to
the points the original one it gets to
the point where woody spoiler alert
tries to push bud lightyear behind the
dresser
he [ __ ] up and the thing ends up
falling out the window
and there's the kid next door sid the
[ __ ] lunatic who blows up his toys
and once again my daughter looks over
and she goes i don't i don't want to i
don't want to see sid
i was like yes it's not a sid's a bad
guy and i thought i could kind of cue
cutesy my way through it she goes i
don't want to see him i go really
she goes yeah and i was sitting there
going all right what do i do and then i
just see her
put her hands over her eyes and i'm like
you're all right buddy she goes daddy
i'm scared i go you want to get out of
here she goes yeah i go all right let's
grab the popcorn
get your starburst the popcorn and lean
over i go she wants to go he goes i know
i'm sorry
because he tried to prep his kid
for uh for sid or whatever so we ended
up leaving after like a half hour
walking out of there they handed us some
mickey mouse ears thanks for coming
right
until we leave and as we're leaving i
see this cute little cartoon that's
going to be there
you know in a couple of weeks i go you
want to go see that
she goes no no i don't and then we got
in the car
she was eating her starburst and i go
okay don't eat the whole bag you're
going to get sick she goes okay
so we're driving and she's like she's
like dad
why does sid torture his toys and i'm
thinking wow it's
torture that's a big word it's pretty
good it's like yeah you know i go well
you know
you know mommy and daddy always hug you
and say we love you and all that she's
like yeah
i don't think his parents do that
she's like oh she's like dad i go what
she goes
i don't want to go to the movies anymore
it's just like okay okay i gotta i gotta
wait till you like
you know six or seven and i'll start
going there i think it's a combination
that they're trying to get i get the
marketing it's like well the parents are
there with the kids let's
you know we got the kids there i'm
taking the kids to the movies money
let's get their their money when they
want to go themselves so i understand
why they're doing it but
anyway um
i don't know it is what it is it's it's
so i'm just gonna [ __ ] chill till she
gets a little bit older
and i also think too it's really loud
also compared to just like watching it
at home
like when we're at home it's not is like
i don't think ominous
or something you get into a dark movie
theater like i'm telling how [ __ ] old
i am i literally brought earplugs
because i didn't know how crazy it was
gonna get
because now like um i think
throughout history movie theaters
have always felt threatened that no
one's going to go anymore
and it goes all the way back
to television when television first came
out they freaked out they're like oh my
god they're going to have
a movie screen at home they'll never go
to the movies again
and you know the tvs back then i mean
how big they were but they felt
threatened by those things and that's
why
the whole 3d thing came out creature uh
creature uh from the black lagoon in 3d
all of those 3d move that gimmick came
out
to try and make people to continue going
to see movies
and uh i don't know there's a whole
i used to know the whole [ __ ] history
of that but there was a number of things
that happened and they've always been
afraid that people weren't going to go
up but people still go out despite the
fact that we
now literally looks like you have a
movie screen people have home theaters
and all of that
and [ __ ] comes out at the movies and
like a month later you can go see it
you can see it at home like you guys
don't know this [ __ ] already but anyway
um so i think one of the things that
they did was they just
one of the things that they did to
combat it was they made it the sound
system crazy to the point
it's like you're going to go see ac dc
or something so
my ears you know are a little shot from
playing drums and
this guy started up a [ __ ] jet i
didn't have my [ __ ] earplugs in and
there goes my right ear so um
that's why i bring the uh the earplugs
but anyway so that was my
my day but we ended up having a good
time i just ended up
taking it for a drive and um
we went up on mulholland and i love
doing that
i like doing it at night and i also like
doing it when we're having like
weather and that type of [ __ ] just
because it was really interesting to me
as we were going over them
if you looked out on the hollywood side
out to like santa monica
it was uh you could fly no problem
visual visual flight rules right vmc
with the conditions and then on the
other side
in the valley what look like [ __ ] like i
would not fly in that
seemed okay by van nuys but when you got
over towards burbank it looked like it
was raining
and um what are the rules you can't fly
if it's like
the ceiling is below 2000 feet or
visibility is less than uh
three statute miles and that's what it
looked like it was over there and that's
when it starts to get like
you know scary enough in a helicopter
but super scary in a [ __ ] plane
because planes are like sharks if they
stop
they die right they got to keep moving
forward right where a plane
a helicopter i could just stop and be
like i don't want to go into that [ __ ]
and i could literally just hey there's a
nice big backyard
i think i'll set it down here get yelled
at by the owner
but i'll be alive being yelled at
so um yeah i learned something really
fascinating like if you were in a plane
or a helicopter and you were to fly into
the clouds
which helicopters are not allowed to do
but say you [ __ ] up or whatever
you were texting somebody and you went
into the clouds
um what you if you really have to first
one of the first things you have
to do is you got to see what radial
you're flying
because you want to then turn around and
fly the exact opposite so if you're
flying 3-6-0 you'd want to fly 1-8-0 out
and the thing is if you don't clock that
if you're so [ __ ] panicked
um when you go to make your 180 turn
like you're in the clouds you can't
there's no frame of reference it's over
now and if you don't [ __ ] get your
[ __ ] together
and stop trying to look out the
windshield and look at your gauges
your gauges your your um your
instruments right
um you're gonna lose control and you're
just gonna [ __ ] die like that quickly
you lose all sense of what's up and
what's down
all of this [ __ ] that i'm learning for
this [ __ ] exam is so fascinating how
that that the liquid
the fluid within your middle ear
is in your eyes work together
and if you take one of them away in a
plane
you're not going to know whether you're
upside down right side up
in a nosedive or in a climb unless you
look at your instruments and even when
you look at your instruments right
your your [ __ ] brain because that
system of your eyes and your ears isn't
working anymore will give you
false information like if you start to
accelerate
you're going to get this essential
sensation that you possibly that you're
tumbling backwards
and you have to block that [ __ ] out and
look at your instruments and be like
my brain is wrong this machine is right
it's [ __ ]
it's incredible it's amazing it's a
really like
incredible thing to learn um so i'm
having a great time i'm just
gonna try to enjoy because it's so much
[ __ ] information but i'm just like
you know even if i flunk this [ __ ]
thing
i'm better pilot just trying to get this
this uh
this rating so anyway let's get back to
the movies here so
i was talking about how loud movies are
and
how um you feel like you're going to an
ac dc concert when you i remember when i
saw that superman vs batman it was just
like what the
[ __ ] is [ __ ] crazy um and speaking of
ac dc i watched the original gone in 60
seconds and i swear to god the lead in
it
hb haliki i believe is how you say his
name
um is a dead ringer for [ __ ] bon
scott
i mean he look he looks like bon scott
in the let there be rock
concert video from paris um
other if he wasn't wearing a shirt i'd
be like i didn't know [ __ ] bond scott
was in this movie
um i highly recommend the original gone
in 60 seconds
because uh this guy h.b hillaki
was like [ __ ] this i'm making a movie he
was a stunt man
actor the whole thing the real deal he
shot it on a low budget
the audio is out the [ __ ] window
like i don't know what happened to the
audio but i feel like they shot for
about
six weeks and then they realized that
they couldn't use a lot of it so there's
a lot of [ __ ] where there's narration
over footage that you know you'd be like
you know like a wedding and you're
seeing all this
footage great footage of them being at
the wedding and you just hear
talking over it like all right we got to
steal all these cars
well how the hell are we going to do
that yeah just leave it at me well as
you're just watching people eating and
dancing and laughing and you can't hear
any music or any sound from the wedding
but what's so fascinating
about this movie is let's it was like an
hour 35 minutes long
is that the let's say let's just say
it's an even
90 minutes long you watch 45 minutes of
a movie
and then the last 45 minute literally
the last
half of this movie is one car chase
is the police chasing him as he tries to
after he stole
the last car that he needed and
that whole eleanor mustang which i
thought ford came up with
actually this movie called it the
eleanor
mustang they called all the cars they
wanted to steal women's names i don't
know if they kept that i didn't numbers
really saw the nick cage one in 2000
but they came up with all these female
names so they could talk about them on
the phone
and the cops would know what they were
talking about so they'd be like yeah we
got to get we got to get you know
jackie we got to get eleanor so ford
ended up making an eleanor
i guess or tried to make an eleanor
mustang
because of the nick cage one and this
guy's estate
sued ford for copyright infringement
because they came up with it
and another interesting thing
was they actually were making a sequel
the original came out in 74 they were
making the sequel this hb haliki guy was
making a sequel
in 1989 he was shooting in buffalo
gone in 60 seconds part two um
was going to come out 16 years probably
1990 would probably
come out after the original and
they were shooting a scene and there was
a stunt where this water tower was
supposed to come down i imagine they'd
have the car drive underneath it or
something like that
a cable snapped the water tower came
down
hit a telephone hit a telephone pole the
telephone pole came down this is like
some wiley coyote [ __ ] i was saying to a
buddy of mine
came down hit hb hilicky and killed him
instantly
and that was the end of that sequel um
and then they i don't know then they
rebooted it
in 99 shot at 99 and 2000
which everybody thought was the original
at least i did when nick cage did it
so check that one out if you can i
forget where the hell i was
watching that it might it was either
amazon prime or like hulu
which hulu by the way i don't said all
of a sudden now they had some new
[ __ ] thing and they were like yeah
we we need to know where you are when
you're watching it it's like well i'm
not [ __ ] doing that
why do you need to know where i am i
gave you the zip code on my [ __ ]
credit card doesn't that kind of let you
know where i am we want to know exactly
where you are
um so i might be done with those guys or
i'll let my wife figure it out
um so
anyway so i watched that and then i
watched this other thing called
uh that a buddy of mine recommended
called trip
of compassion this is pretty [ __ ]
wild man trip of compassion
is about people who
suffered some really traumatic event
and they have uh i always say this wrong
ptsd post-traumatic stress
yeah ptsd and they're finding that
you know
like almost like if you have like
an injury to your body
okay and you get like a masseuse and she
can work it out or he can work it out
you know
hey work it out like and get get you
going again some sort of trauma to your
body your brain is sort of the same way
where you get all your muscles get all
glued up you get frozen shoulder
whatever like that like your brain
operates on a lot of those same
principles obviously it's a different
it's not the same type of things like
you can have a masseuse massage your
[ __ ] brain so but what they're f what
they've been trying to use
is psychedelics right i know i'm late to
the party a lot of people rolling their
eyes like they already [ __ ] did it
and cured themselves of their childhoods
or whatever but this is new to me
so i watched this thing called trip trip
of compassion
on vimeo and
um it was three
three people they were all from israel
and one had been molested another had
been kidnapped and the other one
saw you know bomb went off there was a
terrorist attack and then he was one of
the first people
who ran up to try and help people and he
just saw
what no person should see so
um it showed them they were taking
ecstasy
which was new to me i had no idea i
thought ecstasy was what you took when
you went to go
watch somebody with play music from his
laptop
and those dj shows um
so anyway they were showing it
in this documentary it really helps
these three people out
who's in and like someone like myself
who's just trying to like finally
got to this amazing place where it's so
[ __ ] up i'm not angry anymore it's
it's like
weird it's like somebody [ __ ] moved
out
you know i got all this space now i
don't know what to do with it
um in fact like
today so much [ __ ] happened
that would have escalated into a fight
and it didn't like
i heard i would you know downstairs
pancakes were being made
who doesn't like pancakes who doesn't
like pancakes
on a sunday morning right so
i'm upstairs i'm studying my flashcards
for the instrument thing
crushing it do it in the morning when my
brain's nice and fresh
i get it out of the way so it's not
hanging over my head and i can focus on
the family right
uh anyway i come downstairs
everybody's had pancakes and i'm like
hey is there any batter left for
pancakes
and like no
no there isn't and i'm sitting there
like
all right you know
not like i really gave a [ __ ] but i know
if it was the other way around
because this has happened if i've been
which is another reason why i shouldn't
get mad because i've made like i have
these healthy style pancakes that i'll
make
for myself my daughter loves them if i
make those
and you know one time a number of times
i made them and i wasn't thinking
because they were just healthy
i don't think any buddy wants them my
wife will come down and she's like
he didn't make enough for me right and
then i'm just
i'm like oh you can have mine then i
just give her mine is what i do
but it's like a [ __ ] thing where she
feels like
what do you like not give a [ __ ] about
me so basically that's what happened to
me
but you know that whole thing is a
one-way street right which i've learned
which used to piss me off and now i'm
just like all right [ __ ] whatever
i'll make my healthy pancakes i [ __ ]
go to the fridge
for the last ingredient that i need
which is the greek yogurt
and there's none in there this is
european style yogurt oh i can use that
i pick it up i can tell there's not
enough in there
and that would have that would have set
me
the [ __ ] off right but i didn't
didn't i just said you know what [ __ ] it
and i took out chinese food that we had
had the night before and i just heated
it up
and i got to tell you something it
sucked most of it sucked the orange
chicken sucked i sound like what we suck
today
the offense sucked the defense sucked
who's okay
playoffs um but the
the beef and pork was delicious so
i just playfully gave my wife [ __ ] and
she laughed about it and said you know
what you're right
and then i go so i come downstairs on a
sunday morning
and there's just remnants of golden
brown pancakes that we're eating and i'm
over here eating [ __ ] beef and
broccoli
and i'm gonna clean up the kitchen she's
like you don't have to clean up the
kitchen i said oh yes i do because then
i can hang this whole morning over your
head and she laughed and i left
and it was [ __ ] over and i also made
my point next time there's pancakes
being made now
include old freckles right um
and then a thousand things you know
taking my kid to the [ __ ] movie
theater
thousand [ __ ] things happened you
know
she didn't want to go she had a tummy
ache just all of this [ __ ] she was just
being moody or whatever
and i was just like okay buddy all right
buddy and i didn't have a problem with
any of it
i get to the parking lot the guy tells
me hey park over here
i parked there i put it between the
lines he does that thing can you move it
over a little
bit i literally have a backup camera i'm
between the [ __ ] lines i'm looking at
the guy
i did say i dropped one f-bomb
i i was in the car and i'm back and i'm
like what the [ __ ] did i got a lady said
what the [ __ ] does this guy want from me
and then my daughter's like oh dad
that's a bad word i'm like you're right
buddy you're right i got out
guy gave me the thumbs up i'm like
whatever
you know i go to the movies my daughter
gets scared i wouldn't get mad at my
daughter but i would get mad at myself
and
and in in all of hollywood for [ __ ]
putting those trailers out and
[ __ ] goddamn corporate [ __ ] isn't it
enough you got me
i would have done that i would have been
cursing walking down the street as my
daughter would be telling me to stop
yelling stop yelling and stop curse none
of that [ __ ] happened
so anyways this goes back to
i'm watching this [ __ ] and i really
think the whole reason i had this
breakthrough
or at least the watershed moment for me
was i took mushrooms
i'm not trying to steer people into this
[ __ ] i feel weird trying to steer
talk about this i'm just being honest
this is how it worked for me
i took mushrooms in [ __ ] february and
i had that feeling
of of be loneliness and not feeling
loved and i'm like what
i have a beautiful wife that i love and
kids what the [ __ ] is this and then i
figured it out
this is how you felt growing up this is
still lingering this is what you haven't
been dealing with
so this [ __ ] thing i think this is
why my buddy sent me this because he
goes yeah dude you should watch this
so these people are taking ecstasy now
i'm not gonna lie i have a
i have a prejudice against
ecstasy all right ecstasy to me
is for some [ __ ] rich kid that went
to a private school
that is either trying to get back to his
absent at his absentee parents
or is just a spoiled rich kid and has no
[ __ ] boundaries
so um it seems to me the way to go
with these psychedelics and [ __ ] if
you're going to try to use them for
therapeutic
purposes is you ask around and you find
a reputable place
and you do a guided
like uh trip i think
as opposed to just taking the [ __ ]
and being like oh my [ __ ] tv is
[ __ ]
getting bigger man is it gonna fall on
me like i was doing no
so um
i don't know i got a um i was watching
it and i was
relating to the people in it
like turning a corner
and i felt good for him and then i felt
the whole [ __ ] thing
ironic where it was called trip of
compassion
and it was in israel and then you're
watching everything that's going on over
there
which is not compassion it's all [ __ ]
hate
on both sides and then people need to
[ __ ] you know
i guess take guided trips to get over
the [ __ ] so
maybe that's what you need to do over
there
is you just have guided
everybody on both sides
takes mushroom or ecstasy in a with
guided professionals
like the same way they're giving out the
vaccine everybody lets go of all of this
[ __ ] they forgives everybody and then
everybody remembers
that everybody there is a human being
that deserves love
and to feel safe and to uh you know
enjoy an unoppressed
existence wouldn't that be nice but
it's not how it works it's not how money
works
so um anyways check that out if you can
if you can't would be uh cool and uh
speaking of of tragedies i didn't
realize this uh
this is a comedian that i actually lost
touch with
probably back since i i moved out to uh
los angeles in the 2000s but i found out
this
comedian great comedian really just one
of the absolute like just a
sweetheart she really had like a special
thing about her
uh katie lazarus unfortunately passed
away from i believe breast cancer
really bummed me out um my wife was a
big fan of hers
i feel bad that it was back in january i
just i just found out my wife told me
about it but um
just wanted to give her a shout out say
rest in peace and truly one of the
just really nicest people that i've met
in my adult life forget about in this
business so uh sorry to hear about that
news
um all right now how the hell what do
you segue
how do you segue out of that what do we
do bread and circus here
do we talk sports my celtics lost to
paul verzi's knicks today
um we're going to be playing the wizards
starting on tuesday the knicks winning
today they clinched home court
the opening round yes nick fans knicks
fans
their knicks made the playoffs first
time in eight years
and they have home court in the opening
round
and they're playing great defense and um
it's the most excited i've heard paul
verzi about
the knicks and and he gets excited
every year this is the most excited he
has been
it's been about the knicks possibly
since i've known him
um oh no no no wait wait when they had
uh
uh what the [ __ ] was it who's that asian
kid he was a point guard for them who
he was just an overnight [ __ ]
superstar he ended up going to the
rockets
when that kid came on and was doing what
he was doing verzi
was losing his [ __ ] mind what the
hell was his name
ah my brain's the worst uh
speaking of asians shout out to uh
i hope he say his name sohai ohtani
i almost said of the california angels
that's how old i am the anaheim angels
red sox looking to sweep the angels i
watched all most of all three games this
weekend we got a [ __ ]
solid squad over there i'm loving these
red sox
and we were up uh was it five to four or
four to three i forget what the hell it
was
we're down to like one out matt barnes
total stud gonna close it out
been striking out the side and he threw
a [ __ ] 97 mile
mile an hour fastball on the inside
this ohtani kid [ __ ] turned on it and
hit a
bomb around the pesky pole
gayle it's the old [ __ ] right there
fred we still got a couple guys on the
bottom of the ninth but um
i'm loving watching the red sox um i
think we gotta you know after last
season
um you know finishing dead last granted
you know our manager alex cora was
suspended
um which by the way he's back showing
the guy's
value he is a great [ __ ] manager you
know i didn't realize that the whole way
the astros got
busted was some fan at home figured it
out
um that whenever they won the home game
they heard that [ __ ] trash can i mean
that's [ __ ] amazing
it is amazing that you could bang on a
trash can and no one would [ __ ]
notice
um some guy at home
i mean that is a fan
but i would have to think that it was a
fan of the astros because why would he
be watching all their games
and crack that co i mean i put that
right up where
when uh this stand-up comedian by the
name of bill burr said the nba was fixed
early in the 2000s and everybody said i
was nuts
and then they said they had a mobbed up
ref all right they tried to do the whole
uh oswald oh he acted alone oh diddy
is that what he did [ __ ] out of here um
sorry um you like how i [ __ ] weaseled
my way in there a little pat on the back
all right bruins verse washington
capitals
game one last night i'm taping this on
sunday
uh oh she oh jesus scored in overtime
um just one of those games we were
chasing him the whole game one nothing
one one
two one two two uh
that was it three two three three and
then they won four three or something
like that i don't know i i
you know i got kids so i i'm in and out
of the room and all that trying to
figure it out
um seemed like a we look like a really
this one looks like it's gonna go seven
i hope
anyway but uh i do have to i have one
petty thing here
i am so sick of nhl fans
comparing marshawn and wilson like
who do you think is worse okay
just for the record marshawn is five
nine
183 okay five
nine with [ __ ] skates on
all right if he lays down you measure
his nose
[Laughter]
sorry um
and [ __ ] wilson is
6'4 220 okay
now i'm not saying that either one of
these guys
you know i understand why people get
upset by the way they play
but like marshawn is from like the ken
lindsman
family tree all right wilson is like
claude lemieux with cam neely's body
okay that guy will end your [ __ ]
career what does marshawn do he spears
you in the balls that obviously sucks
you might not be able to have kids and
he's gonna lick your face
okay but he's not like you know coming
in like a freight train
and slamming you boarding you slamming
your head off the [ __ ]
glass or you're laying in a prone
position
and he's jackhammering punching you in
the back of the [ __ ] head all right
i understand while non-bruin fans don't
like marshawn
i get it i absolutely get it but you
know
compare him to another rat all right i
don't want to [ __ ] hear that wilson
you know he's kind of the same no he
isn't
he isn't you're talking about a guy
knocking off a convenience store
and you're comparing to somebody who
goes on a [ __ ] shooting spree
at least that's how i see it all right
five nine 183
is not six four two twenty
so shut the [ __ ] up with that i i don't
wanna hear that that
you wanna compare him to another [ __ ]
rat i don't have a problem with that but
but enough with this
this [ __ ] and also in defense of
defensive bolted them
everybody's acting like they're the only
two guys that play like that in the
whole [ __ ] league
it's like it's becoming like hillary
clinton and trump
um there's plenty other [ __ ] in the
democratic and republican parties
all right having said that and the
reason why i picked claude lemieux
with wilson was out of respect because
as much of the sociopath as claude was
the [ __ ] guy could play and wilson
can play he had a great goal
took advantage of uh uh what's his face
his broken stick
um um charlie uh
jesus christ mcavoy broken stick
and uh just did a nice little give and
go went top shelf the guy can [ __ ]
play and like claudia mew you look at
the guy going this guy can play there's
no reason for him to be doing this [ __ ]
um which i understand you could say
about our guy too okay i get that i get
that but let's stop acting like it's an
equal threat okay that's that's my
[ __ ] opinion you don't like it i
don't give a [ __ ]
all right and you can waste your time
moving your thumbs on twitter talking to
me
i ain't reading your [ __ ] all right
with that let's let's [ __ ] do
a little bit of zip
[Music]
um you know if you're a business owner
who's hiring
you you probably face a lot of
challenges when it comes to finding the
right person for your role
uh talk about some of the challenges of
hiring yeah you want to get some
[ __ ]
who's only going to be there for like a
week you know i get somebody's going to
be stealing all [ __ ] pens and pencils
you want somebody to do the job
was that right um that's why hiring can
feel like trying to find a needle in a
haystack
sure you can post your job to some
job board but then all you can do is
hope the right person comes along
which is why you should try zip
for free free at ziprecruiter.com when
you post a job on
zip
it gets sent out to over 100 top job
sites with one click
then zip recruiter match matching zip
recruiters matching
technology finds people with the right
skills and experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply
in fact sip
is so effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
time is money you can't beat that it's
no wonder over 2.3 million businesses
have come to zip
for their hiring needs so while other
companies overwhelm you with the
with way too many options ziprecruiter
finds out what you're looking for
the needle and the haystack and right
now you can try zip
for free at this web address
ziprecruiter.comburr
once again remember to go to this unique
place zip recruiter
r-e-c-r-u-i-t dot com slash burr
b-u-r-r one more time zip
brook roto the smartest way to hire all
right
well that's it only a couple reads oh i
love that
one read i mean it's less money but
it's also less stress on my brain um
jesus that [ __ ] guy's flying alone
did you feel that just shook my whole
[ __ ] garage out here
um all right man mandalorian pinball
likeness now a lot of you guys sent this
to me
says hi bill love the podcast thank you
what are your thoughts on being
on the side of the mando pinball
machine the mandalorian for those of you
uh
who don't watch sci-fi is a new branch
off of the star wars
franchise john favreau
is running that over there and now
they're coming out with merch and one of
the things they came out with was a
pinball machine
and old freckles has his face on it very
small
but i am in there uh wondering when the
last time you played pinball
if you got a free game from stern the
pinball company
um all right i did not
but if stern is listening i i would love
one i don't have any room for it but i
would i would just get rid of some [ __ ]
for that um i love pinball
last time i played pinball i was in uh
asbury park
um new jersey i was doing some uh what
the hell was i doing out there
i did some gigs right before i was doing
snl
and uh we were down there me and club
soda kenny and my wife
uh took the kids out there's an arcade
right down there across from where they
used to have the uh right around the
corner right the street from where they
used to have the uh
the carousel with the horses and [ __ ]
and we went in there and they had all
the classic old games
and uh there was some game in there nia
just said i'm i'm the [ __ ] at this and
she just kicked my ass like three times
in a row in it
but i played pinball in there i'm a huge
fan
of pinball um i did not get a free game
from the stern company
maybe i can get a company discount um
i don't know i just think it that's the
coolest thing ever
um yeah
i've done a lot of cool things but that
is one of the coolest [ __ ] things
ever to be
um part of that part of that world so
there's three different levels there's
there's the entry-level one
it's like a camaro right there was the
rally sport the berlinetta and the z28
and uh i don't know
those things are pretty [ __ ] sweet i
will tell you that all right nfl newbie
hey billy belichick uh after listening
to you talk about the nfl for years i
decided to give it a shot i watched la
the last super bowl and could see myself
watching it
so i will be following the next season
when it starts up nice
now i just have to pick a team to root
for as a swedish man i feel like i have
to reclaim
my pillaging heritage and pick the
vikings what do you think dude i think
that's [ __ ] perfect
because i never would have picked that i
would have said just
be a fan of the uh the buccaneers you
know watch tom brady and uh you know
what's his uh [ __ ] gronk and maybe
julian edelman
if he comes out of retirement a year or
so uh do they have any good players and
do they have any interesting
anything interesting about them thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself all right now well
i have to be honest here
and people from minnesota uh maybe you
want to go to the cupboard right now and
uh go get yourself uh
a big viking take a big viking swig or
something because i have to tell them
the history i have to tell this person
the history of the vikings okay
all right so this is the history of the
vikings
uh they are an original afl team
all right the afl was the last afl was
the third
version of an american football league
using that name
and the nfl was established at that
point
having a board absorbed last one they
absorbed was the
uh all-american football league
uh which brought in the browns
otto graham and paul brown and the 49ers
and a few other teams right
so um the afl starts
an upstart league against the nfl the
nfl laughs at him
but as they laugh at him they they shot
two torpedoes at them
the first thing they did was they figure
out which owner had the deepest pockets
and that was lamar lundy
and he had a team called the dallas
texans so what the nfl did was
immediately or
award dallas a franchise 1960 the dallas
cowboys
the only reason why they did that was
because
they didn't want um
they wanted to take out the top owner
they want to try to chop off the [ __ ]
head
so basically you're immediately you had
you had no professional football team in
dallas and then overnight
you could choose between seeing the
dallas cowboys get the [ __ ] kicked out
of them
by all of these famous nfl stars that
never came through
jim brown and all of those guys or
you could watch some upstart league
across town so
they did it deliberately to try and bury
the texans which worked
because the texans ended up having to
leave and went to kansas city and became
the chiefs
the other thing they did was um
they offered one afl team an opportunity
to join the nfl
and that was the minnesota vikings so
the minnesota vikings were an afl team
that never played an afl game
they just jumped ship on all the other
owners so that's what they did they
joined the nfl so 1960
they came in and in 1969
the only title i believe they ever won
they won an nfl title in 1969
played the chiefs in what was still
called
the nfl afl championship game i believe
and they lost the super bowl they were
the last nfl
um champs so
then after that retroactively those
first three four afl
nfl title games were then called super
bowls
i think that's how it is for some reason
i'm feeling like though the vikings
first the chiefs was the first one um
1969 nfl
title game let's see who was it the
vikings vs the browns
this is the 37th and final game
minnesota beat the browns am i [ __ ]
good or am i [ __ ] good
yeah they beat the browns so they have
won a title if they counted if they
counted they counted nfl titles
now let's check the vikings because i
want to make sure let's see the
packers lost beat the chiefs in the
first super bowl
and then they beat the raiders and then
the jets beat the colts and then the
[ __ ]
vikings lost to the chiefs that's how it
went
so let's look up the minnesota minnesota
vikings
here's the tale of the tape
um
let's see wow that is like
the quickest credits let's see playoffs
uh nfl championship game yeah they've
won an nfl championship that's all they
have
they've won some division titles they've
never won a super bowl
they actually were the original buffalo
bills in that they lost
four super bowls in a very short period
of time
they lost back-to-back years to the
dolphins and the steelers i believe in
like
74-75 or something like that they lost
their raiders in super bowl 11
and they lost the chiefs of super bowl
four
so you're basically signing up for a
franchise
that has a history of breaking breaking
people's hearts
vikings let's see vikings projection but
you should definitely jump in because
i feel like it has to just
mathematically speaking it has to be
coming to an end here
um okay
vikings hopes
for 2021 let's see what comes up here
five prospects the vikings have four
takeaways from the vikings regular
season
yeah i don't know i don't know who their
[ __ ] quarterback is anymore
i don't know but here's the deal you're
from you're from [ __ ]
scandinavia right you should definitely
pick the vikings
they've [ __ ] the bed for 60 years other
than in 1969
with joe capp i believe it was i think
joe cap was it was he the guy
who i think finished on the patriots and
we drafted a guy named joe plunkett and
he's like i'm out of here and he was the
first
latino quarterback to win a uh
to win a title a championship but for
whatever reason they don't [ __ ] count
those so
um i would definitely jump on that
bandwagon
you know and it's easy it's easy to ride
out
tom brady's last seven seasons
and be and be a fan of them i think the
vikings are the perfect team
for you to fix for you to pick i think
if you actually flew over here and went
to a game
you'd love minnesota um the twin cities
it's a great place to be and you'd see
a lot of uh there's a lot of you know
scandinavian bloodline out there
get yourself a juicy lucy you'll have a
great time minnesota is one of my
favorite places but you can skip the
mall of america
um and what you should do instead is
watch a highlight of the minnesota north
stars
and that stadium i would watch that
instead of going to that [ __ ] mall
all right nfl newbie i read that one all
right cdc
verse america oh boy hey billy boy [ __ ]
tits
billy boy [ __ ] tits first off my lady
and i were impressed to see you in
nashville at the grand ole opry
what a [ __ ] venue to perform at
anyway
the cdc just announced today that as
long as you're fully vaccinated
you can resume life without a mask or
staying six feet apart
but there's still a lot of americans
that don't agree with the doctors and
are still going to wear a mask because
they don't want to be
misrepresented as a republican is that
why i don't know that not that i am one
but when do you think people will start
listening to the professionals
and turn off the [ __ ] news um never
never until you know somebody
shut down cnn and fox news and all that
crap but even then
then they would just turn to social
media
and like they would just listen to each
other and i just think you know we're
not smart enough
and there's also too many channels
to just do the news now you have to have
crazy sensationalized [ __ ]
like i don't like feeling bad so i don't
watch the news and i have not watched
the news
i don't know what's going on
i watch a little bit of it you know i
saw what was going on
you know in in in tel aviv jerusalem and
all of that and
in palestine and all of that stuff is
starting back up again which is [ __ ]
heartbreaking
um and you can't come up with a solution
and i just i don't know just having kids
and stuff and i just see those
bombs being shot and just knowing that
they're hitting people's
children there's just no way around it
on both sides and
the whole [ __ ] thing is heartbreaking
because um
i went over there i saw both people i
saw israelis i saw palestinians they're
beautiful people
i just wish that you know
i wish there was a way human beings
could live
without oppressing other it's like in
order for me to have you have to have
not
and there's just different degrees of
that
throughout and it's this [ __ ]
inhumane business model that just needs
to stop
globally
[Music]
and it all starts with mushrooms um
anyway i ch
i have no solutions i challenge anyone
to delete facebook and turn off
the news just for a week to see the
little bit of peace that comes to your
life
i don't know maybe i'm a stupid idiot
too no you're not the second you think
that you maybe you're an idiot
means that you're smart enough to know
that you don't know everything and that
is
of all the [ __ ] i've said this
person here that is great advice
delete facebook turn off the news just
like
stay off social media for a week don't
watch the [ __ ] news
and it's amazing your life becomes nice
and small
i'm gonna go to the store and get some
butter you know
and you can kind of slow down and
[ __ ] enjoy
life as opposed to just like uh
that chicken little [ __ ] that's on like
social media and
uh in [ __ ] news anyways the person
says all the best to your family below
is the tweet from the cdc let me read it
here
open the link open the link
update okay may 13th if you are fully
vaccinated against cover 19 you can
resume activities without wearing a mask
or staying six feet apart
or staying six feet apart except where
required by federal state local
tribal or territorial laws including
local businesses and workplace guidance
that's [ __ ] awesome
that's awesome all right i love it
all right democrat i can't wait to go to
a baseball game
i can't wait to go to sporting event i
can't wait to go out and do stand up
and make people laugh i did stand up uh
i did two shows
at uh two nights three shows at the
comedy store
and i got to tell you something after a
[ __ ] year and a half of doing
stand-up
standing next to highways and then
strips of grass behind [ __ ] motels
being inside and not having any other
noise
to distract me i i felt like i was on
steroids
like i was swinging a weighted bat for
like a year and a half and now i'm
getting up there like
swinging like a wiffle ball bat and i i
kind of noticed that with like
all the comics were [ __ ] murdering i
came walking in
i saw sebastian for the first time
and i was looking to say hello to him
and i was in the back room he kind of
came out instead of coming into the
green room he just left
by the time i realized he wasn't coming
to the green room he
he left i haven't i haven't literally
not seen that guy since this [ __ ]
started he was [ __ ] destroying
and i could see it in his face like how
much fun
how great it was to be back so very
happy for him him by the way
sebastian sebastian's doing a movie with
robert de niro how [ __ ] crazy is that
it's [ __ ] amazing um so congrats to
him
all right democratic socialism
he's doing i should say doing another
movie his second film
with robert de niro um all right
democratic socialism
uh dear billy for father
uh when i hear democratic socialists
speak
i often agree with with what they're
aiming for oh god did i start the
socialism discussion on here
healthcare availability taking care of
fellow men
and women with excess resources etc yeah
nobody is against that
well some people are against healthcare
availability because they're just like
i can afford healthcare so [ __ ]
everybody else
that's another one of those i have and
if you have not
you [ __ ] figure it out
[Laughter]
my house is up on a hill and i look down
on you
suffer um
anyway the problem is that they push
this on a federal level
all right this is going to educate me
because i don't want this at this point
in american history
it's impossible to have that type of
system banks and corporation have so
much control over everything our country
does
see wars well thank you thank you for
actually getting to the root of the
problem
instead of being like you know it'd be
too expensive it's like
why is it too expensive do you know when
i was a kid so much [ __ ] was made here
and ever since they went overseas to go
to get away from the unions with
who's kidding who they got a little
[ __ ] they acted like a bunch of
[ __ ] divas
and the corporations it wasn't 100 to
corporations just being cheap [ __ ]
uh they said [ __ ] this we're out of here
but now that they're
making the profit margins they are using
sweatshop labor
they're like if they made it here then a
t-shirt would cost
six thousand dollars
it's like no it's that the only reason
why that is because you're trying to
keep the same profit margin
that you have when you're not paying
people [ __ ] and you're oppressing them
in other [ __ ] countries
that's why it costs that and what do
they always do they blame their
shareholders [ __ ] [ __ ] anyway voting
for this type of power to be handed to
the current government
would just end in abuse um obamacare
bankrupted the medical industry because
it was written by insurance companies
um i don't know if that's true or not
but that if if they wrote it yeah i
could see that happening this is the
field i'm in
and i'm concerned for the next few years
uh for the next few years of healthcare
availability
all right this person isn't is an expert
here at least compared to me
oh compared to me everybody's an expert
okay local level politics need to be
stronger and people need to be
accountable for who they send to
washington to represent them
that's true that's true otherwise
blindingly saying yes
this sounds good let's give them the
power to do so that's what i do
is irresponsible without watching
everything they do closely from there on
after
yeah i mean
that's an airtight argument you're 100
right
i remember somebody telling me a long
time ago that like what
people just sort of vote for president
every four years most people
but how important your local elections
are
um i think people you know they just the
genius of this [ __ ] thing is they got
you running on a wheel
so you don't have time but i swear to
god if we paid attention to these
[ __ ] politicians the way we pay
attention to sports
myself included um we would definitely
have a much better
more accountable system um
so there you go hey look at that look at
those last two [ __ ] people who wrote
in this is some smart [ __ ] here stay off
social media for a week and don't watch
the news and uh
pay attention to who the hell you're
voting for and uh follow up to see what
they do
don't blindly say yes because they got a
blue tire a red tie
or you know be fair to the ladies a blue
bra or a red bra right
all right socialism first capitalism oh
god damn i i
really opened a can of worms here people
i don't even know i couldn't give you a
definition of either one
hey andrew can you please get bill to
read this i've been writing to bill for
a couple of
for a couple of times before and would
be so grateful if you
get this to him thank you very much all
right dude i gotta already say
you are suspect that you you're an adult
and you wrote a sentence
i've been writing to bill for a couple
of times before
all right hey billy hey bill pasty [ __ ]
dangle balls redheaded redhead [ __ ] burr
i'm going to keep this short because i
know how hard it is
to read out loud for you yeah it's about
as hard for you to write a [ __ ]
sentence um i am a fellow liverpool fan
from
tunisia living in the netherlands ah
[ __ ] it's a second language
my apologies you are smarter than me god
damn it
i thought for once i wasn't gonna be the
dummy anyway
um i don't get why americans only
believe in extremes oh
shut the [ __ ] up i don't know why you
dumb [ __ ] if you want to give us
constructive criticism
why you would open it with a statement
like that you just put me on the
defensive oh
have you figured it out have you figured
it all out in the netherlands
i've been there with the illegal drugs
there and [ __ ] all of these guys with
itching their [ __ ] heroin scabs on
their neck trying to sell you a stolen
bicycle
that's not an extreme do whatever the
[ __ ] you
want here in holland i guess it's just
in um
amsterdam anyway either socialism or
capitalism
nothing else the ideal in my
in my opinion the ideals in my opinion
system is
actually a mix between the two god damn
it this already sounds interesting a
country with capital
with capitalist economy but also the
same
time social policies like nationwide
healthcare
and affordable universities
yeah that's a tough one that's like hey
what if you just did heroin once a month
then you didn't get addicted to it
um anyway countries which are successful
with this the netherlands where i live
oh you pat yourself in the back finland
norway denmark
all right i want people who aren't white
from the netherlands finland
norway and denmark to write in to me and
i want to know
if this guy's version because i'm
assuming this person
is a white dude and that that this is in
fact
the equal opportunity closest thing to
perfect
that it can be uh i will tell you this
uh
one of the biggest [ __ ] i ever met was
in denmark this taxi driver
i forget what he said but he turned
around at the end of the ride because
you americans are so stupid huh
and i oh my god i [ __ ] i almost
punched that guy in the [ __ ] head
i was so [ __ ] he was such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] too
one of those [ __ ] you know six foot
four
130 pound [ __ ] european guys
fold like a [ __ ] lawn chair as they
say on crime stories
i stayed in that cab my wife was trying
to drag me out and i [ __ ] just sat
there trash
oh yeah you're so smart you drive a
[ __ ] cab and he's like
oh he's put his [ __ ] [ __ ] hands up
who's can who i didn't almost punch him
in the face i was just [ __ ] mad and i
yelled at him that was the real thing i
wanted to punch him in the face
all right but i was afraid because i
watched [ __ ] uh
what is that guy we had the drugs type
two uh
taped to the inside of his leg and he
[ __ ] goes to jail or
the [ __ ] is the name of that movie which
i will never watch again it was so
[ __ ] terrifying
uh yeah i wouldn't want to go to jail
but he was a big [ __ ] he had a big
mouth and he was a big [ __ ]
um anyway yes it will lead to higher tax
rate but also you see
where that tax goes and you won't have
to sell your house in order to pay for
your hospital bill
all right so you're telling me in your
country that there's nobody
abusing their position of power
and uh you know there's no filthy
stinking rich person there
or you're saying there are some but not
as many and it's spread out better
i don't know i understand why this can't
work in the u.s because
like what dave chappelle said on rogan
to rephrase
higher tax rate works in countries where
the people trust their government
also u.s is controlled by corporations
um i kind of believe that all of the
countries at this point are controlled
by corporations unless you have a
dictator
am i crazy thinking that i do like how
you guys are rejecting our food
[Laughter]
all you had to do was look at us to know
you didn't want to put that [ __ ] in your
body
um all right once again every other
country seems to be better than this one
and they've evidently solved all their
problems
anyways side question i'm a 20 i am 29
years old
and i would like to start playing drums
is it too late for me no
because you're probably still in college
because you don't have to [ __ ] pay
for it
like those [ __ ] college student
lifers i met when i was in finland
um no it's never too late it's never too
late it is so much [ __ ]
fun it is so much fun um if you live in
a place where
um noise is going to be an issue i
recommend
buying the v drums
the electronic kit if you can afford
that or a used kit
if you can't um and i also recommend um
looking in and learning all about
hearing loss
in in uh tinnitus or however the [ __ ]
you say that word and get yourself those
vic first
headphones and really really be careful
with your ears
all right also he said you're doing
great learning french i speak french
and you are doing great i'm currently
learning dutch and i know how hard it is
to learn a new language well i had to
set that aside because i have to like
i only have so much space in my brain
where i'm going to pick it back up
when i'm on the other side of this
[ __ ] instrument thing uh ps thank you
for the podcast it helped me through
some tough times and for being open
about the [ __ ] you were dealing with
it helped me realize certain things
about myself look at me i'm like a
[ __ ]
bald freckled male oprah go [ __ ]
yourself you [ __ ]
all right man well thank you for the
important i'm happy uh your life is
better
it's doing better um girlfriend of three
years caught cheating
oh boy oh boy boom
all right dear bill burr oh wow this
guy's in such a [ __ ] bad place right
now he didn't even trash me
um i just found out my girlfriend the
love of my life of three years
has cheated here's how i found out she
went out to get drinks one night at 6 pm
and came back home at 10 p.m and
proceeded to cuddle with me in bed
the next day she is at work and i am on
my day off at home
her ipad is linked to her iphone whoops
when she gets a text message on her
phone
it pops up on the ipad at home
she got a message from some guy and it
read
hope the dick helped last night
oh god i confronted her about it and she
couldn't give me a straight answer
i decided to leave the house and stay
with the family member for the weekend
once i came back to talk to her
face to face with her she admits to
having sex with the same guy
twice she also said the night she was
out drinking the guy suggested they go
to his car
and initiated to have sex i've also
caught
her texting another guy about how deep
she can go
implying she can suck long dick and how
much dick she can take
oh boy uh we have been through a lot
together
from meeting each other's families to
being there for each other when a loved
one has passed away
even just saying i love you every day my
family loves her and her family loves me
i don't get why she would do this after
all this time i really love her
but want to teach her a lesson any
advice is helpful yeah dude you got to
get out of it it's over
um you shouldn't want to teach her a
lesson you shouldn't want to do anything
vindictive to her
what you should want to do is
go out and meet a person that's going
gonna love you the way that you're gonna
love them is not gonna do that to you
that's it i'm sorry you're going through
that um
yeah uh but
you have to you gotta you gotta leave
that one because
that's gonna be
you know what happened it's gonna happen
again so i hate to be the guy to tell
you that but
um the good news is you could have been
married with kids and then find
found that out and then you you'd be
linked to this person for the rest of
your life because you have kids together
so you can get away clean
i would suggest going to therapy
i would suggest crying about it i'd exp
i would suggest talking about it to
other friends and i would suggest giving
yourself
all the time you need to get over it and
really get over it
before you try to meet somebody else and
um
it is what it is it sucks it happens
uh but like i said the upside is you
didn't find out
you know after you were married with
kids all right that was kind of a bummer
uh you know
what's funny that expression over here i
heard in england that means if somebody
[ __ ]
banged you in the ass which make a
bummer makes
or hey man i'm bummed means that that's
what it is which makes way more [ __ ]
sense
because i've never understood that whole
thing like i was a bummer i'm like what
does your ass have to do with something
being you know
bad well i guess if somebody banged you
the ass unless you wanted it it would be
a
wait let's see here bummed
english slang
definition of bum is slang for feeling
upset
no no in england isn't it in england is
something different
maybe it was a different country the
word is funny because it means something
different in the u.s and in the uk
the u.s to be bummed or bummed out as
means to be sad or depressed
oh [ __ ] did it they click on the right
one
in the uk to be bums means a man has sex
with you by putting his penis in your
hands
there you go and we can end on that we
ended on a laugh all right that's it
uh right he got [ __ ] bummed by his
best mate
um a couple of [ __ ] stuck together
all right that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
i'll check in on you
on uh on thursday all right that's it